hey guys Ryan Wright is over here Ariana
so today we're gonna check out this
video called why is everyone obsessed
with eating the booty Ariana can relate
to this she's constantly having people
obsessed with wanting to eat her booty
she hangs out at dark clubs any of these
things you said most of this before we
film nothing about we're talking about I
did not tell any of that song about a
seating that was the first thing you
said oh I came in here I was like I love
getting my pass eaten it's not I did not
I know you're gonna edit that now the
thing I love getting my yeah I'm gonna
play back a few times too I love getting
my posse I love getting my ice evening
alright here we go let's watch this [ __ ]
no I haven't eaten ask that's like
saying oh no the day I wake up craving
to eat and I never like what you can
register with as far as the mass goes I
know a lot of people that like doing it
and hey it's an acquired taste that some
people think anything's delicious I
wouldn't buy it myself but live your
life what I dress yeah under the
pretense that I against you shall with
you right before and I get the cleaner
[ __ ] everybody's gluten-free vegan
spot they can eat ass eating believe may
sound disgusting but on the bright side
it's only 35 Weight Watchers point so
classy whether you'd ask I'm cool you
know you just have to this body class
while you're doing it you know you just
can't do it in a way that devalues you
all these rappers they made it socially
acceptable because they're just like
talking about the rapping diagram and I
was even boo to you in the club last
night well I don't have that one you
need a bro you got it yeah of girls on
the block you never got your rest yeah
I'm the one who brings it up that's how
you separate the freaks from the a seer
because if you don't need that you're a
freak I actually once had a friend tell
me that if I wasn't eating asked that I
wasn't having sex so I guess I'm a
virgin
in 20 years eating ass is gonna be the
new [ __ ] like there's gonna be
classes at college and there's gonna be
books about how to do it well I would
love to be the person who go to their
boss and they listen I could take off
these are the dates on my calendar I
gotta and located a Christmas Day yeah
with my family there's a holiday called
national booty day a part of me thinks
that eating as is disgusting but at the
same time I used to think broccoli was
disgusting when I was little I kind of
like broccoli now you never know if my
girl wanted to experiment with ass
eating that the total deal-breaker
because if I'm so bad at sex
you need me to now lick your [ __ ] to
please you well just stop trying to make
this work it's not gonna happen
sorry about the video let's talk about
this topic
for a little bit okay I personally have
never eaten out an ass I've never eaten
as I've I'd like to make that very clear
I'd like to try them one day baby I'm
putting this on camera no one mentioned
that I put this on camera to hurt I once
got my not by my girlfriend but prior I
got my ass you know if I got tossing
salad I think yeah this person said they
wanted to lick me from head to toe I
like the song and I didn't realize how
literally they meant it did she lick you
from head to toe she really did I was
actually from toe to head anus that was
correct it felt surprisingly good
yeah I felt surprisingly good they don't
like I am a finger up in or anything
like I was like this no I wasn't like
just facts of life
this is what we're talking about today
you say you never try it
um I don't want to eat an ass what about
having your ass even I don't want that
you don't want that you don't see you
don't like butt stuff at all no a lot of
problems really badly like I have like I
got a colonoscopy at two years ago I'm
not gonna let someone mess up my eyes I
don't think anything that will come from
my boy he was like no you can never have
anal sex as you you should have seen
this channel getting there well I'm
sorry that's just today's topic no I
don't wanna even ask
especially guys how do you feel about
people who do it do you care no of
course they don't care okay not
judgmental towards people video yeah
yeah okay love that subscribers eat as
much as you want I just don't want it to
be mine yeah just don't need Ariana's
ass on that note if you're new to the
channel you can subscribe you the real
rejects if you're new to the channel
ridiculous first ones a lot Ariana will
be starting up a channel soon so keep a
lookout for that you can follow us on
Facebook Instagram and Twitter and I'm
liking this video so much just do a
shout out to a fan
Armando Garcia found your channel about
a month ago and have loved it ever since
can I get a shoutout Armando Garcia of
course you can get a shout-out he's a
young and he's a young in this one okay
I'm gonna give you some some like
fatherly advice yeah okay eating a Shh
I'm gonna be appropriate here one day
your balls are gonna drop if they've
already dropped I'm letting you know if
you're a backs s to YouTube he does he
follows your channel your parents might
have set like some privacy settings to
avoid a few sites let me talk about a
few sites
xvideos calm thank you are people still
into that I think so youporn calm to
bait sex calm is like Pinterest it's so
girly not worth it so what you can do is
just go to the privacy settings take
that [ __ ] off of uncensored off of what
you want off a sense hurt because what
you want to do is practice and learn
until the moment actually happens
porn was the best education I ever got
practice well you know like you could
practice humping I wonder if your
parents are watching this they're not
Ryan Wright telling you to masturbate
but if you in fact are a kid I did not
say any of this I'm gonna get sued